Transformers Universe has been a long
time coming longer than you might have
hoped thanks to an executive decision to
rebuild the entire game in unity just a
year ago but it's a move that seems to
have paid off as free-to-play
browser-based MMOs go it looks the
business the game revolves around
classic pvp raid action albeit with a
tactical twist rather than just charging
in fists or rocket first into battle the
idea is to make use of each classes
unique abilities and work together as a
team to take down the opposition while
there's no character creator universe
does feature a whole set of new
transformers across 12 classes designed
exclusively for the game as well as some
familiar favorites + by mining Energon
from the environment you can tweak a
character skills to focus on a
particular area of expertise or create
more of an all-rounder all robots have a
particular key skill though tank
characters like the monster truck
transforming showdown focus on brute
strength with a shield sharing ability
letting them protect weaker members of
the team like snipers healers like
meltdown consists on the periphery of
the battle buffing melee characters like
frontline with a healing gun for
prolonged attacks ultimately it's how
well a team can strategize and use each
of those characters abilities together
that's the key to winning battles you
can use a few characters to distract a
group of opponents peeling one off from
the group and into a deadly ambush for
the tank full hide around a corner ready
to absorb a flurry of laser fire fling
it straight back edits creator if it all
gets a bit much you can transform into a
vehicle and hightail out of there taking
refuge near a healer to recharge or if
your character gets destroyed during
battle you can choose to redeploy it by
spending energy on on it or pick another
character from your stash and send it
into the fray sadly I didn't get a
chance to go hands-on with the game so
it's still up in the air as to how well
the combat and vehicles handle and
there's a question over how well
developer jagat handles all the
inevitable microtransactions especially
when there are so many collectible
trends
former Zhan offer but transformers
universe looks promising let's hope it
sees a release soon